en
un dialogue qui se contemple guyancourt
propose une double exposition des
techniques différentes qui se répondent
elles font parler leur environnement
patricia un photographie la nature
essaie d'attraper la la poésie de
l'instant et surtout l'instant qui
bascule qu'est ce qui a manqué ce qu'il
ya après
poésie une permanence qui ce quelque
chose qui se transforme en permanence je
travaille essentiellement en noir et
blanc je trouve que la couleur est un
peu bavarde
un calme un silence qui fait écho à
l'inspiration de nathalie houdebine la
plasticienne se nourrit du territoire du
sol de la marche et crée aussi en noir
et blanc
c'est mon côté mis les minimalistes
certainement je pense qu'avec une seule
couleur on peut tout faire
d'ailleurs que le noir le pur et des
très puissante
si on dilue si on peut obtenir des
grilles extrêmement doux et j'aime bien
pouvoir jouer aussi avec ses contrastes
toutes les valeurs que l'on peut trouver
donne énormément faire de relief des
profondeurs
une rencontre initiée par la ville cette
double exposition prend racine au
printemps 2010 8 avec le concours rare
talent de guyancourt une complémentarité
douceur un noir et blanc riez et yang
plein de choses comme ça qui font que
c'était une évidence qu'elle était elle
pouvait exposer ensemble et qu'elles
sont complémentaires
leur amour du noir et blanc n'est pas le
seul point commun des artistes nathalie
haut débit n'est patricia - sont passés
par l'école des beaux-arts de versailles
un parcours parallèle qui s'expose
jusqu'au 2 février
[Musique]